Let's go to our voicemail number two, one
nine, two. David P you can call anytime of
day and many people do call very, very late
at night or early in the morning, the morning,
depending on what your life schedule is. Here
is someone who is not pleased with my pronunciation
of a particular presidential candidates name.
Take a listen.
David, how's it going man? This is Michael
from Missouri. I want to tell you something.
I'm a little, I'm a little peeved with you
about you pronouncing someone's name wrong
on the show. I think it's on purpose and I
think it's very disingenuous of you. I think
you know who I'm talking today. You pronounced
her name tool. See Gabbard I think it's clearly
tool C cable Bayard. Okay. I'm very angry
with you. You need, you need, you need to
start pronouncing your name right or else
I'm going to keep calling in about this.
Well listen, I stand corrected as I've mentioned
before, English is my second language. I did
not learn English, uh, as a baby because it's
what I heard around me. My parents did not
speak English to me when I was a kid because
I didn't live in the United States. I lived
in a Spanish speaking country. So there are,
it actually is, it happens quite a bit that
people write in and they say, David, you're
not pronouncing this correctly or not pronouncing
that correctly. Uh, I sometimes, I don't know
how people pronounce their names, so I stand
corrected and I do apologize to anyone that
was offended by a, anything that I've ever
said on the program. I will even go further
if I've ever offended anyone with something
I've said on the program. I apologize to you
unquestionably and unflinchingly with absolutely
no preconditions whatsoever. We've got a great
bonus show for you today.
The NCAA has taken a major step to allow student
athletes to be compensated sort of while they
are college athletes, not for the athletics
themselves. Um, but for their likeness. We
will talk about that. We will talk about a
taco truck that served ice workers. Then apologized
and then apologized again. And we will also
talk about the U S house of representatives
voting to recognize the Armenian genocide.
A story of much interest to many in our audience.
Interestingly, got a bunch of emails about
it. All of those stories and more on today's
bonus show, become a member at join Pacman
dot [inaudible]
com to get instant access or become a patron
at patrion.com/david Pakman show, we will
speak to you on the bonus show, the David
Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].